tropical depression fred is lashing the
dominican republic and haiti with heavy
rain and powerful winds and could hit
florida this weekend fred is the sixth
named storm of this hurricane season and
we are only just now entering the peak
of that season in this morning's eye on
earth we're looking at how emerging
technology could help warn of the
dangers from hurricanes it's a
revolutionary new tool that could make
it easier to predict the intensity of
storms and also importantly where
they're headed senior national and
environmental correspondent ben tracy
has more
so we're close to the moment of truth
this is not the moment of truth i mean
the truth is the hurricane this is the
easy bit
they look like bright orange sailboats
but nobody will be taking one of these
for a joy ride their hurricane hunting
drones destined to face some of the
fiercest storms on the planet
these things have no idea what they're
about to get into exactly exactly
richard jenkins is the founder and ceo
of saildrone a california company that
created these winged robots we were
there as they towed two of them out into
the ocean off the coast of jacksonville
florida how revolutionary could this be
in terms of the data you we get about a
hurricane and this could be
transformational and how we understand
how storms develop you know increase our
chances of warning people onshore or
what dangers they might face if it works
these solar and wind-powered autonomous
drones will provide the first ever data
and video from the surface of the ocean
inside a hurricane relayed in real time
back to saildrone's mission control at
this former naval air station in
california which houses its orange army
a fleet of more than 100 drones we have
nothing else that has done this so it
would be extremely new and extremely
valuable greg fultz is a scientist with
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration he says right now most of
the information we have about hurricanes
comes from hurricane hunting airplanes
that fly into storms and drop probes
from the sky
sail drones are expected to provide far
more data right from the storm's
so-called engine where the sea and air
meet this could provide important new
insight into how strong a storm is and
where it's headed we've seen in recent
years hurricanes that seem to suddenly
go from a one to a four a two to a five
is that some of what you're hoping to
understand how does that actually happen
yes exactly that's called rapid
intensification and that can be
especially dangerous near landfall
[Music]
last year hurricane laura rapidly grew
into a monster storm with 150 mile per
hour winds the most powerful hurricane
to ever hit louisiana
and in 2017 hurricane harvey went from a
category one to a cat 4 in just 24 hours
before hitting texas and causing
catastrophic flooding possibly 30 inches
of rain in some localized spots
hurricanes are the costliest natural
disasters in the u.s totaling on average
54 billion dollars in wind and flood
damage each year
warmer ocean waters due to climate
change are making hurricanes stronger
and a warmer atmosphere means they also
hold more water
this gives us a whole new level of
intelligence as to what's coming for us
and hopefully exactly where they're
going to land sale drone is deploying
five hurricane hunters three from the
caribbean and two from florida each one
is 1500 pounds and designed to withstand
hurricane-force winds and 10-foot waves
once the next hurricane forms in the
atlantic the sail drones will converge
on it traveling up to 50 miles per day
ideally sailing right into the storm
from all sides
do you find yourself in the weird
position of
kind of hoping for a hurricane to test
this out we do it's kind of a weird
situation where you obviously don't want
hurricanes for the safety of people but
we really want to see them to test
technology
you know it's a little bit like sending
kids off to college for the first time
the company has already tested its sail
drones in the rough waters of the
southern ocean near antarctica and a
larger version has been deployed from
san francisco bay to map the ocean floor
on a trip to the hawaiian islands but a
hurricane is still a voyage into the
unknown to go through a hurricane really
is kind of the last frontier so
yeah we'll see how it goes
for cbs this morning ben tracy
jacksonville florida
well we're in the midst of hurricane
season
footage of the surface of the ocean in
the middle of a hurricane for the first
time i'm looking forward to that yeah
the devastation is so bad but what we
can learn from these things and from
them is amazing